[Music]
in just weird news she is weird just
weird Canadian accent this is submitted
by a leggo my eggo singer grimes shared
her training regimen which includes some
very weird things unlike this one Grimes
the singer a lady not a great name
do you know she okay the last time we
talked about her and the first time I
ever heard of the powder was almost
bought that shirt she needs some Sun
kinda looks lost you know when you said
that I pictured uh the UK ones like so
bright in here
do you say police car yeah I thought I
saw please front of the back but I guess
nothing you guys are dumb yeah there's a
lot of black and white wood because
she's a cyborg okay that's this is yeah
how old is she cause in that last
picture I thought she was like 17 when
you guys said when you said Grimes for
some reason I thought it was Leigh Anne
Grimes yeah me too but you know old lady
so I saw that although I don't know I
mean Google that really quick she's 31
Wow shoes she looks good Brenda's 31 she
looks like 17 looks really young let me
tell you why she's named Cara Sherman is
she still with its training record no it
was very short-lived froze remember she
invited as a Lea Banks and then that
whole story texting hit her about like
his dick oh Lord
and he said you're terminated he's just
like he's cold yeah so she posted on
Instagram these photos with those are
beautiful it's a really cool pictures
this caption she's on lava
she's launching and adidas sponsored
thing with Stella McCartney
collaboration so in the caption it says
adidas tell us about your training
regimen Grimes
my training is a 360
approach I first maintain a healthy
cellular routine where I maximize the
function of my mitochondria with
supplements such as nad plus a set so L
carnitine maybe you can help me yeah
acetyl l-carnitine magnesium etc this
helps promote ATP and is incredibly
visceral what's ATP adenosine
triphosphate I if I may interject for a
second this is all [ __ ] what she's
saying but it's all using big words
that's that's what it's like you said
okay so what's ATP like the average
person reading this no let me tell you
the rest and it could be very productive
don't even get the point I don't get the
point of what she's doing let me tell
you the record so go get slapped okay
okay from that point I spend 2 to 4
hours in my deprivation tank this allows
me to this allows me to Astroglide to
other what is it that aloo present and
future in the afternoons I do one to two
hours sword-fighting session with my
trainer James Lu we go over the
fundamentals we know James Lu yeah James
the dragon Lu I don't know jus
choreographer thinks it's stupid as hell
burns like she's paying me a fat check
so whatever
le w right Lu W yeah we know this guy he
came to one of our reads oh wait was I
there yeah you're there who is he Oh
anyway
so James blue we go over the
fundamentals that work the obliques
course stabilizes shot us to James and
he's a famous like stunt coordinator and
like yeah he's been in he's like he's
done Jackie Chan stuff like oh yeah
yeah well now he's doing crime stuff
yeah good yeah okay course stabilizes
and triceps as well as a few tricks to
wind down from this I spend 30 to 45
minutes on an incline hike at roughly 4
to 4.5 miles per hour
arguably the most efficient efficient
workout
I then spent minutes stretching before
heading into the studio where my mind
and body are functioning at peak levels
with a neuro plastic goal between fifty
seven point five and seventy one point
five alpha C's parentheses which is my
preferred range for my blood type
I've outfitted my studio with the
highest grade of red light it is pretty
much 1,000 sq F is our sauna square feet
infrared sauna Thank You Hana then comes
over and we do a screaming session for
22 Tana that's the only one I think is
really effective yeah well I said low
boil the honey tea that maximizes my
vocal proficiency oh what the [ __ ] was
she screaming I figured right yeah she's
a singer I have also eliminated all blue
light from my vision through an
experimental surgery that removed the
top film of my eyeball and replaced one
with an orange Ultraflex polymer that my
friend and I made in the lab this past
winter as a means to cure seasonal
depression I go to bed which she made it
in a lab and then inserted it in her eye
brows our excuse me I think the honey
tea is the only thing that actually
loves you right because a lot of singers
use honey tea is who they're throw it
she just make this [ __ ] to troll or
is she like custard I was thinking that
this can't like in it I do this is like
about it this is her Adina's was it like
hashtag la life or whatever know there
were hashtags that's hashtag a smc
hashtag adidas Harley Harley Harley
hashtag created with the Divas hashtag
gentrify mode or ginger fry modal Mordor
like from Lord of the Rings confuse
there's a caption so if I could not drop
a little bit of science but just say
outright that her entire training
regimen bard knows this makes absolutely
no sense it's all pseudoscience yeah and
all the words that she's using she's
just throwing arguably the most
efficient was the thing between a 4.5
okay is she funny I mean she's just
rolling oh I hope
she strikes me as being someone that
takes herself away - seriously just by
her adidas photos like you know like if
they were kind of jokey photos and then
that cat but you don't know she's a
funny person and then she did a serious
kind of photo like that's really nice
like that one guy that does all the the
Jenner fatos or was it generous Jenner
I don't know so the reports are just
like so Grimes is saying she did this
experimental surgery to cure seasonal
depression because they like that's an
illegal surgery
remember that model that changed an eye
color and pretended to be that that one
diseased thing we're not disease a
genetic like okay so she had one brown
eye on one blue eye and she became
famous as a model because it was like
this genetic thing and she was like need
more representation in the in the
industry and blah blah blah
representations yeah he said that's a
sob story about her getting bullied and
stuff but it turns out she just used to
wear contact on one eye I think she's
got this surgery to replace her eye
color that surgery you can only get it
in like India and that company that does
it a bunch of people have been going
blind from that surgery oh my and like
thank god she's my it just turns black
like the pupil just takes over the wall
eye and it just turns black it did that
happen to her not yet
so I know I've heard about this surgery
to change your eye color from freaking
TI's wife tiny she did it for her eyes
yeah they're like ice yeah you do that
the thing is it still looks kind of fake
because they just put a filament
underneath your actual eye or whatever
and it still looks a fake color it just
is like surgically in your eye but
anyway so I'm wondering if that's a
similar surgery like how else can you
remove the blue it's an experiment on
like you signed with her friend that's
in the lab what lab really seem like
that's why it sorry TIFF akat all boys
she's misusing all those that's why it
sounds like a troll maybe her friends
Elon and they were doing in the lab you
could be completely right
they're making fun of like la culture
like yeah I have an ace ie bull with a
girl three granola but he says you know
it could feels like she's that it's like
she's yeah she's trolling the LA
[ __ ] like new HP right Andy
Kaufman that's like level satire were no
one knows that she's joking but yes
because I've heard conversations and
every interact with people bits and
pieces but when you string together so
it could be the honey cheese legit
though so like that's they see that's
about why would you fire fire yeah why
would you throw in one legit thing to
make these publications they said they
reached out to adidas to get some sort
of insight like is this satirical or is
this for real like but they be having
nothing back to them they're like let's
just see how this plays out they don't
want a favicon they don't want to offend
the fans that actually believe this
[ __ ] do you just get behind that you
think so because it's such a big company
all their products signaling and all
their brand talk they would probably
want to be on point so that's why I feel
it has to be legit because why would
they endorse it there's a troll post
maybe she's trolling them to campaign
they're gonna be like the new adidas
Flat Earth and then it's like a new shoe
that comes out and it's all for people
like this you won't hear someone [ __ ]
up about flatters yes oh oh for sure if
you ask our generation or let's say
people above 25 and above it's like 1%
or 2% it's very low but they've actually
shown it's 2% too high yeah that's
really they've shown that the younger
generation due to just a bunch of
factors a lot of maybe misinformation on
the internet YouTube you know
alternative news sources they'll say
like there's some that will claim that
there's not just one son there's
actually two sons and our solar system
just a lot of weird information that's
wrong that it's I forget this statistic
it's an alarmingly high amount of people
25 and younger that genuinely believe
and they're a side not a troll if do you
think the earth is flat and instead of 1
to 2% it's something crazy like 8% like
it's it's no way it is too hot you
we're dealing even more stupid as the
point you could fly in a plane and see
the curvature of the earth like if you
didn't believe like that hyah but it's
not something that we can't the domes
changed the windows then is the moon
flat and they're like no we've seen the
moon the moon is round agree that every
painting in the filament or whatever
there's like a dome and they're like the
Moon and Sun are hanging in the filament
but there's [ __ ] astronauts taking
like videos in space that's like like
why can't we just look up that real
quick of and be like okay we're done the
fact that they use GPS in their everyday
life and that's based on the earth being
a sphere [ __ ] funny there's so much
cooler scientific things that are
plausible such as multiple dimensions
great quantum physics is bugged and
dominating yeah that could be true
that's next level let's like why would
you please flattered epic universe it
will blow your [ __ ] mind is that a
part of the simulation theory oh it's
like that there could be like many many
different worlds of many pairs of all
parallel because it's like we're a
hologram broken off from a bigger piece
of a large chunk and like when you break
apart a hologram it shows the same
picture on all the pieces hmm so it's
like parallel universe of different
probabilities yeah yeah it's so I'm one
of those maybe they're worth it to keep
them in one of those we would be sitting
in different chair it's like Rick and
Morty yeah like where they have all the
different versions that's tight
and in every single world crime will
still be a loser
she uh she just sends a message just
kidding news well that put if the post
is true if it's trolling if it's
trolling a genius yeah if it's not I
hope what she does is back tracks and
goes like yeah it was trolling that's a
good
you